we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p the
voicemail line is made possible by our
good friends over at linguist which is a
simple and super effective language
learning app which I've been using to
refresh my french in advance of a trip
to France for work that I have upcoming
it uses artificial intelligence
algorithms to recognize areas of
weakness to speed up your language
learning and you can try it for free no
credit card needed at Ling viscom slash
Pakman that's Ling vist with a v.com
slash Pakman okay today's voice mail is
a compilation there is a very very angry
trumpet named Jimmy from Philly he is
extraordinarily furious with me every
time he calls he was featured on live
calls several weeks ago it has come to
my attention that he is calling all the
time he's leaving voicemails sometimes
multiple voicemails in a row about
things I don't even understand sometimes
very very late at night so we took just
a few seconds of a bunch of his
voicemails imagine calling a show this
frequently and being this angry take a
listen
David Jimmy from Chloe so you think it
would be unreasonable to expect more the
call bar L after almost two years of
investigation
David Jimmy from Philly you're doing the
hatred mail segment miss justice here
and injustice
David Jimmy from Philly I just saw your
interview with Jesse Lee Peterson where
you're talking about Christine Ford and
you had stated that and floss
allegations were made against you and
because the allegations were so
obviously not credible that they didn't
go anywhere well I can tell you from
personal experience that that's not
necessarily true
David Jimmy from Philly the heart
Bassett is now in the process of
destroying your narrative on all of your
videos hey pac-man Jimmy from telly
I'm shocked that you didn't open up a
phone line at nine subscribers come on
man who are you kidding
David Jimmy some fella here why won't
you tell your flock of the laws
regarding special council investigations
they cannot release any information on
anyone not charged
you know this yeah apparently that is a
real accent by the way and uh we we are
unsure whether that's Jersey or actually
Philly I don't know I've never heard
anything like it but Jimmy from Philly
very angry very much on the phones and
that is maybe we'll hear from him live
at some point in the future we've got a
great bonus show coming up for you
become a member
become a patron to get instant access ww
join pakman.com coupon code this is 20
20 saves you 40% you get a hundred
percent of the member benefits but you
save 40% off of the price